episode two of house of the dragon  revolves around the high towers and  their efforts to convince princess  rhaenyra that her father king viserys  should remarry and choose the teenage  alison's high tower over the 12 year old  lena valarion who's the better candidate  on paper rhaenyra and her father have  barely spoken since her mother and  brother's traumatic deaths so alison  takes the princess to decept to pray but  this scene means much more than you  might think the high towers are the  lords of old town where they were once  the richest and most powerful family in  westeros the faith of the seven the  predominant religion in westeros has  strong ties there as well the high  towers support the faith while the  targaryens not so much publicly they've  converted but they keep to their ancient  customs and try to limit the seven's  reach by getting rhaenyra to bend the  knee in prayer alison's is flexing her  own strength